The Joe Rogan Experience so Goggins
in the spare time yeah he fire jumps
so this is a dude that's wealthy Goggins
has a lot of money how did he make his
money he sold a book his book can't hurt
me sold the [__] give me some volume
so give me some volume
why is it happening
hmm
anyway so he fired jumps into this area
and look at these Grizzly Bear Tracks
so what what he does is he fire jumps
for the challenge
he doesn't fire jump for money like most
of these guys are fire jumping they pay
you to do it so you do it he does it
just because it's [__] hard to do and
so he sends me this video of these
[__] giant bear he's a size 12 foot
look he's putting right next to his bear
track
so he sends me in this video and I go oh
my God I go don't get eaten brother and
he goes [__] it here it is okay so so
we'll probably have it
an overnight partner here
[Music]
's Grizzy Bear Prince man
look at these [__] dude as big
as my foot
this is a massive [__] grizzly bear
massive [__] grizzly bear look at
this [__] even though how wide it is
this is [__] a massive ass grizzly
bear
and as you see
he walks right through there through
those woods so we are in Big Time Grizzy
Bear territory
[Music]
so I sent him a text message I said [__]
I said don't get eaten brother he goes
[__] it stay hard brother if you see me
fighting a bear help the bear
look what he said to me
hilarious and then he writes Goggins
with like 10 exclamation points that's
crazy